because it's so true and really actors
get it
but you really gave some perspective to
the outside world looking in
like those guys like christian bale when
they do batman when they play
superheroes when they talk a certain way
it's so true because i'm like i always
think i gotta play lex cooler than this
i can't be rosenbaum
[ __ ] no one wants rose and mama's like
luther i can't be like hey clark
do you we should go [ __ ] uh i don't
know
driving my porsche who says porsche and
then
so there was sort of like a reserved
kind of
thing that i wasn't used to doing that i
got used to doing
it wasn't that i completely went okay
tom
that's a word but you have tell me about
that tell the audience who hasn't heard
that
that theory you have yeah that was i
think that was a rolling stone interview
and part of it was like the conditions
of being because uh
you know you and i both play iconic uh
yeah there was like a
when i play um i play the reverse flash
for for the people who don't know on the
show which is like that's the arch enemy
of the flash
and flash is played winningly by grant
gustin and
the the the reverse flash is played
serviceably
by tom cavanaugh and you know they're
they're arch enemies they're
the reverse flash is the
the joker to the flash's batman and
um when you're playing like one of those
arch enemies
you know there's a there's a catalog of
this is how we do it as part of the
pantheon
and the thing that i used to come into
is the debacle
of 10 yards versus 40 yards because
if he's if you're down the street and
i'm like you know to catch me alive
michael
you know i land and boom i do the
superhero thing boom
do you remember this is an aside you're
gonna love this there was a time
in the late 90s uh early aughts
when when they were doing uh michael
rosenbaum
and you were on nbc right and they were
doing a promo for you
they wanted you remember they did all
those promos they wanted you and your
co-star
when they were doing your solo they
wanted you to do this
ready and action
you remember that yeah and they'd slow
it down they'd even slow down
it bled out from the entertainment
industry into sports so that
drew brees quarterback for the new
orleans saints and it'd be like he'd
have a ball he'd be like i remember
watching
oh like eli manning and all these guys
just be like when they're like write
their number like
just kind of looking up right and it's
sort of it's still there
but it used to be at an 85 percent
barometer and now it's kind of comes in
around 30.
but there was that thing where they also
like
they did this too when it was you know
when you were like
you were like you're kind of that kind
of thing away from me
just kind of swaying back and forth
oh yeah he felt so stupid doing these
promos and then you kind of would do
this like
oh wait you know you did like the spin
around i'm sitting on a chair a spinning
chair spinning around yeah
completely and they were going to cut
away but there was
always that great moment when they
didn't cut away you were still like
still kind of looking when you
and so for these kind of like
stereotypical moments to break out of
it's very difficult as you know to break
out of them because
this is how it's done in the comic book
right
right rarely is the guy you know like
who's just like completely
hey clark
you know because clark's like yeah you
know what you're not a worthy opponent
superman even from 40 feet away but you
think but no
because you did this whole thing where
you're like someone's yelling and you're
like or
yeah here's what it is so i'd be like if
it was you and i facing off i'd be like
i'd land bang and i'd be like
and then you'd be like i'm i'll never
you want some fries
you'll never take me alive michael i i'm
i
you need a ride or a cycle
i'm so sorry he's like never mind just
never mind you know
and that was the guy he was ordering the
guy that i was doing on rolling stone
was he was basically ordering
he was ordering food in a restaurant oh
i'm sorry you have that you all just
have water
but it's cool that's the cool voice and
when you're far away i don't know how
many times i've said that where
i'm talking to you know you're right
clark across the room
and he's like and i'm just like clark
they could never hear you
no like what are you saying dude right
i'm not cool when when they air this it
won't be cool it'll be cool now
and how many times have you seen i've
had guest stars come on and they're even
quieter than anybody i've ever heard
and i'm talking to them i'm like um i
need you to check up on this
scientist i want you to check a mama's
like sir we haven't found any
information
i don't what i can't hear what you're
saying and he kept doing it i'm like oh
[ __ ] this guy's gonna be terrible and
then you see it like god that guy was
great
he was so intense i got to do the lower
register voice
it's the magic of the 150 million
millimeter lens where they're like i can
be way over here but on tv it's going to
be like this
i can be as quiet as i want